paula-gearon
Hi, this is Mario Aquino.
I'm one of the organizers for the strange
loop conference.
And this is another episode of Strange Loop
Chats.
With me today is Paula Gearon.
She is an engineer at Cisco in the Threat
Grid Group.
And we're going to be talking today about
an open source database that Paula maintains
that's called Asami.
Before I get to that, I'd like to mention
that Strange Loop this year is going to, start
on Thursday, September 30th, which is going
to be our workshop day.
And the conference proper is going to start
on Friday, October 1st and run two days the
first and 2nd of October, if you'd like to
find out more you can visit https://thestrangeloop.com
for details about tickets and the schedule.
So with that out of the way let me introduce
Paula, Paula, thank you for sitting with me
for this interview.
Welcome.
Thanks, Mario.
So I wanted to talk to you today about Asami.
What can you tell me about Asami?
It's a graph database and it started life
as an in-memory graph database, but recently
we developed it into something which also
stores persistently on disk and looking at
different types of provisioning for being
able to store it in lots of different ways
and locations as well.
But yeah, it's a graph database written entirely
in Clojure and it is there to provide ground
services for Clojure developers who want to
use data in that way.
So can you describe what exactly is a graph
database?
Graph database represents graph data where
a graph in the mathematical sense is essentially
like a network.
It looks like a full series of nodes with
lines, connecting.
We typically think of these things as each
node, each dot, representing some kind of
resource and then the line in between will
have a label and it will be typically in a
direction.
So if I have a resource that would represent
a person, I can have lines in which go off
to the different attributes of the person,
like their name, their address, and things
like that.
And I can also have lines, which connect that
person's node to nodes which represent other
people, either as friends or their manager
or neighbors.
Then we can have knowledge which represent
companies or cities or anything at all, really.
And so it's a very flexible arrangement for
data.
And it provides us really consistent way of
looking at any kind of data at all.
So it's a database that allows you to establish
relationships between entities that you store
in it.
And it's written in Clojure.
Is it a database that also works in ClojureScript?
Originally I wrote it as Clojure and then
I was asked, can you move it up into the browsers?
So we did our principal use for it at Cisco
at the moment is in the browser.
And it's operating as a memory model for an
important product that we've got, which has
a lot of deployment internationally now.
But it also works on a machine running on
the JVM and it's in that state at the moment
that we've been working a lot with the persistence
model how this can be stored to disk effectively.
So the name Asami can you tell me, what is
that?
It's sort of an internal joke.
Five years ago, we started with this project,
which was the Internet Resource Orchestration
hub, IRA, or uncle IRA was a character in
the TV series Avatar the Last Airbender and
our manager at the time really enjoyed that
show.
And he started naming all these, all of these
projects after Avatar characters.
That was I think IRA running in the cloud
was called Tenzin, which is from the Avatar
spinoff.
Well Asami is a character from Cora as well.
Originally I had written a rules engine, which
used Asami and that engine is called Naga
again, another character from the same TV
show.
So what would you say distinguishes Asami
from other graph databases?
Well, every graph database has its own pros
and cons.
I mean, originally Asami was simply an in
memory model for Naga because we wanted something
which where we wouldn't need an external dependency.
I was building it around Datomic and because
we were going to be doing this thing in house,
I was asked well can you maybe do something
that doesn't involve a commercial system that
way, this whole thing could be open source.
And I, if I had thought I was going to build
an entire graph database, I'd have said no.
We weren't aware of DataScript at that point.
I built the basic functionality that was required
because that's all we needed.
But over time as Naga needed to do more things
with rules we introduced more and more features.
And finally, I realized that this storage
system had gained a life of its own and we
broke it out into its own project.
And now it's become dominant work for me.
Where the whole query engine, the query language
everything's been expanding and you know from
that point, it, then I was asked to move it
into the browser.
And so it became a cross platform project
between JVM and ClojureScript in the browser.
So yeah, running our own project that way
did give us the flexibility to make that move.
And it's also given us the opportunity to
introduce new features as we wanted them,
things like aggregates, which, you know, Datomic
already had, but also things like graph analytics.
So we can do queries on transitive attributes.
Or we can find sub graphs where if you've
got two distinct disconnected graphs we can
identify those and, you know, different sorts
of graph algorithms like this are all things
we've been able to implement internally so
that they're really optimized for the data
structures.
You mentioned that Asami has querying capability,
you know, you can't really have a database
without a querying capability.
What would you say inspired the way that the
querying works in Asami?
Two things.
Firstly Datomic so Datomic has specified a
graph querying language, which is written
in using the data structures that make up
Clojure itself.
So essentially EDN, and that's been really
useful to leverage because we can read it
for free, we don't have to worry about parsing.
But the other thing that is based on is SPARQL.
So 20 years ago I was a lead architect on
another graph database called Mulgara.
And that was written entirely for the JVM.
Back then we developed our own query language.
And over time, it became clear that RDF data
required it's own query language standard.
And so a committee was formed, which was the
SPARQL committee.
I wasn't on that one.
I contributed to it, but then some years later
as new features were required, the second
SPARQL committee was put together and I was
on that, I was one of the editors for the
documents.
So there's a whole lot of semantics in SPARQL,
which differ a little bit from Datomic and
because of some of the architectural decisions
that we've made in Asami it made much more
sense to go often with the SPARQL semantics
over the the Datomic semantics.
So the syntax is some kind of a, a union between
Datomic query language and SPARQL semantics.
Mostly in the edge cases.
In most queries.
You're going to find that you can copy paste
something from a Datomic or DataScript, and
just use it on Asami and it'll just work.
But there are a few, a few things where you're
going to find like doing a, NOT operation
or certain kinds of unions where the edge
cases lean more towards SPARQL, interpretation
of the world, rather than Datomic.
So what would you say is sort of a, an ideal
use case for for Asami where, where does it
really shine?
When you've got a lot of disparate data.
So a lot of data that getting from different
places where you want to find linkages between
the data where you want to take data which
may have come from tables, but when you put
it together, you'd otherwise require dozens
and dozens of tables with lots of foreign
joins and things like that if it were in the
relational world.
When you're bringing a lot of data together
like that, then graph databases in general
are very useful that way.
Asami has been designed internally to be optimized
around querying.
It's optimized around querying, but you know,
at the expense of taking a little longer to
load data up.
So if you're going to be doing, as someone
mentioned yesterday 30 transactions a second,
then the timing is going to be slow on it.
But if you're only, you know, if you're loading
your data up once or every few minutes then,
and querying it a lot and analyzing it a lot,
then Asami's really going to shine.
And, you know, Asami can still handle a lot
of transactions, but there are other systems
which are going to be optimized more around
them, and yet they won't necessarily answer
queries as quickly.
You're actively maintaining Asami what is
it that you're sort of focusing on right now
in terms of the feature set that you're trying
to bring to it?
I'm focusing on what my colleagues at work
say they need.
So when someone says like, can I do this or
doesn't that, does this work the way I think
it should then that's my main priority.
But when people aren't asking me for that
I've been working on storage.
We're just coming up to a 2.0 release, which
is where the, the durable storage the not
entirely confined to memory anymore is finally
going to be released.
There's more architecture to happen there.
There are certain elements of it which I'm
really happy with and other things which are
known, could use more effective data structures.
But it works really well at the moment.
And I'm looking forward to just getting that
out the door.
And then we've got more more layers of indexing
and and features that we want to have there.
You know there's tradeoffs at every level.
But we're looking at, at introducing some
of these new features to make the requirements
that my colleagues have, frankly to, you know,
to speed up certain things and to make data
available easily in, in some ways where it
may not be so easy to get to it at the moment.
So in terms of durable storage, what is the
sort of goal for being able to, to persist
the database?
I guess, in, in it's in the, in, in a format
that has already some, some amount of, of
entity data in it.
Is it for replication?
Is it for quick loading, like a database that
already contains ?
So everything's immutable internally and I
have a whole lot of documentation around this,
on the on the project website.
And it, you know, internally the Clojure itself
uses these kinds of data structures.
The last database I was working on Mulgara
it also used that kind of data structure.
Because we have a whole lot of immutable data
structures, so things which never change,
we only add to the storage, this means that
replication is really quite easy.
We can just take things, knowing that they're
never going to change again.
We can then spread it across a cluster because
again, we know that once something's.
been written, it never changes.
And this gives us a whole lot of advantages
almost for free.
One of the one of the things which, you know,
when Datomic came out, it seemed like a revelation
was that you could go back in time and look
at how things used to be.
Ironically, Mulgara always had that kind of
data structure, but we built it 20 years ago
and disk wasn't as cheap as it is now.
And consequently, we needed to clean up any
data that was old that we weren't using anymore.
And, you know, for, for performance reasons
over time, I eventually ripped that, that
code out because it all, that bookkeeping
and cleanliness was you know, had a cost to
the database.
And so I was just leaving these things hanging
around.
And then when Datomic came out and we were
showing that we had this rich history of what
all the data looked like getting to this point.
I realized at that point that Mulgara already
had that, but it just hadn't exposed it to
the user.
Asami has that now and it's been inspired
by Mulgara structures.
I modernized them.
I updated things over the years as I came
up with better ideas as to how these things
should be built.
And yes, a number of the features, which which
Datomic has, which make it like very different
to other sorts of databases before it uh,
are also present in Asami.
You know, I kind of, while I'm not aiming
to do exactly the same sorts of things, as
Datomic at the same time, it has led me to
certain features thinking, you know, I kinda
like that.
I'd like to have my, have that in my system
as well.
And sure enough people, you know, for the
things I haven't finished doing people come
to me and say, when do we get this feature?
So I know that it's wanted.
Community-wise there are I guess groups outside
of Cisco that are either using or experimenting
with Asami?
So a friend of mine started a channel on the
Clojurians slack and a number of people have
been joining it.
I've seen people saying that they're assessing
Asami for their workplace.
I've had feedback.
I've had pull requests to, you know, to create
new features or or to expand on things.
And so there seems to be a lot of interest
about what I'm doing, which is really quite
nice.
And you know, I, I want to be responsive to
the people who are using it as well.
Yeah.
I mean, this was kind of a hobby of mine that
I was doing on the side and I showed my manager
years ago and he said, this looks great, do
it for work.
And you know, I'm in a really privileged position
that I get to do something, which I was finding
interesting for my job.
And, you know, I want to be as responsive
to people as I can be so that I get to keep
doing this job.
So for folks interested in checking out Asami
for themselves, where should they go?
To GitHub.
It's under threadgrid/asami.
It's an open-source project, all the documentation's
online.
I do work hard to try to make sure that everything
is really well-documented.
A lot of times people ask me for how things
are working and I'm able to point them at
docs and that's really paid for itself.
So hopefully if you need to find things, then
you can go there.
Otherwise you can always go to the Clojurians
slack and look for #asami.
If you ask questions, I do try to be as responsive
as I can be.
All right.
Well, Paula, I want to thank you for sitting
down for this Strange Loop chat and for folks
who are watching, if you would like to find
out more about Asami there will be links when
this video is posted to where you can read
about it on GitHub.
Well, Paula, thanks again.
It's been great talking to you.
You're welcome.
Thanks Mario.